(upbeat music)
- Sangria this wine is to
die for what is the secret?
- My handmaiden accidently dropped a bunch
of chopped apples into the barrels.
- Delicious.
- I think it's absolute piss.
- Well I have been meaning to tell you
this morning I had a bit of fun
with my stepdaughter Jenifaria.
- Oh I'd love to hear I've
been having a terrible time
connecting with Britania.
- Then you will love this.
I woke up very early this
mornng, I snuck into her room
and I shrunk all of her wardrobe
so that she thinks she's gaining weight
then I barricaded her in her room
and filled it with mice and
now they're her only friends.
- And that works?
- Oh yes she actually confides
in the mice quite a bit.
- He hasn't called to me in a fortnight
I mean do you think I should call to him
or is that too forward.
- Oh dear.
- That reminds me I did
the most delightful thing
with my stepdaughter
Serenity just yesterday.
- Oh please do tell.
- I took her on a trip to the forrest
we had a lovely picnic then I drugged her,
dropped her in a remote location,
put gobbs of honey on her
and let her fend off the bears.
- That is classic.
What did you do to your stepdaughter?
- I hope it was fantastically twisted.
- Yes it was I.
Good morning sweet angel
I brought you breakfast.
- [Voiceover] Go away.
- Good afternoon delicate
flower I brought you a puppy.
- [Voiceover] Get out of my life.
- Thought you'd enjoy a late night snack.
- [Voiceover] Burn in hell demon woman.
- Wicked, wicked things like poison
and forced betrothals, all of it.
- Well done.
- You keep her in line.
- Oh all finished, Britania's
going to love these
and they're going to keep her little feet
so nice and warm.
And by that I mean horribly
freezing cold all the time.
- Just as I suspected.
- Don't worry I'll put a spell on them.
- [Voiceover] Let's go Victoria.
- Thank you for having us.
- I'm horribly wicked I promise.
I guess the scarf is off
the table, it matches.
It's Heather grey.
(upbeat music)